Oh
there's a great line by Albert Camus he
says life should be lived to the point
of Tears in other words we should strive
to be moved to be transported to be
shaken we all want to be touched by
something greater than ourselves that's
a difficult thing to do and so I become
really obsessed with the idea of
experience design which is basically
hacking experience hacking subjectivity
now what is experience what is
first-person subjectivity well in a way
that evanescent flux of sensation and
perception that is in a way all we have
in all we are it's the multi-dimensional
matrix of first-person experience
unfolding moment by moment it's the
voice in our head that lets us know that
we exist
so how can we inform how can we script
that narrative how can we be the
director of our own movie so to speak
and it turns out that the trick is
attention to hack experience you got a
hack attention a fantastic article by
Diana Slattery says that what is
required is the capture and control of
attention to create a state of deep
immersion of deep absorption and this
kind of immersion is a prerequisite for
any kind of interpersonal persuasion
transformation or education to take
place in other words any kind of phase
change in consciousness any kind of true
inspiration transformation you know
catharsis requires this deep immersion
the state of focused attention and again
that being the key to experience that
being the key to scripting subjectivity
the narrative of your own life and that
seems to be ultimately the key to
happiness the meaning of our lives this
kind of deconstructing of our
consciousness and tweaking our
perceptual apparatus to kind of engineer
a kind of neural Nirvana to trade in
real virtuality x' to train and
subjectivities that is what it means to
be human and that is what we are
increasingly becoming
masters at doing at distilling and
creating and I love that